not be around the bush but clean around
the bush come on now
what's this let's go i don't know what's
going on who's this guy no it's
happening
science happening today
okay sports fans what's good we're here
man
we're here bro we're actually here we're
always here
we're always here for you guys we're
gonna be here every monday and every
first and every fifteenth
for literally forever forever so if you
don't like us leave now because you're
stuck you're stuck with us
you're actually stuck it's long for you
um but guys let's jump straight in
you know where the link is it's in the
description click it it's going to take
you to the patreon page
you fill in some details really basic
[ __ ]
and then you've got a wealth of content
to enjoy you've got a wealth of
interaction to have of us
and you've just you just getting just
mad mad bangs for your bucks
exactly so it's um if you didn't know if
you're new here and you didn't already
know
it's three pound a month 10 p a day
run the p my p bro run it
just run it cheap is cheaper than chips
you said it before it's cheaper than
chips it actually is cheaper than chips
so yeah man um let's not [ __ ]
let's not talk about the foreplay about
that let's move on to
the main sponsor gang so guys
today we're funking with manscaped
just for today only today though quick
one-off
we're going to mess with manscape today
um these guys are they're
they're just the number one dons in male
grooming technology guys
there's no more archaic grooming like
there's just not this is just that's a
thing of the past bro it's time for us
guys to step up and be proud of the fact
that we keep our [ __ ] together we keep
it clean so guys
straight to the point the code is smg
the website is manscape.com
you get 20 off and free shipping you
already know what to do again link in
the description
click click type type sort it
out bro sort it out because this is the
biggest hud
studies have shown that guys
who use manscaped yeah get
i don't even know if i should share this
seven to ten times more pum than the
regular man
there i said it shared this
but was fda approved yeah man's broken a
few laws by just bro yeah
they told me not to say anything but i
just couldn't help myself because the
fact you guys deserve the truth
of course mandem who used manscaped
seven to ten times more likely to secure
your pawn
that's just the way it is it's just the
way it is man once you clean up
you clean up hey come on now once you
clean up
you clean up so there you go bro guys uh
20
are free shipping code sng manscape.com
let's not uh let's not waste any more
time don't be around the bush
but clean around the bush come on now
what's this what's good i don't know
what's going on who's this guy
no it's happening science happening
today your synapses are
bouncing i love it all right man gang
[ __ ] you know those jokes but yeah as
you said 20 off
free shipping sng code manscape.com
let's not [ __ ] about
um moving on to the fun fact so remember
i'll talk to you about a few weeks ago
about um
animals and random facts and stuff and
blah blah so i've got another one for
you
um there's an animal called an
anti-chinese or an anti-kenis i don't
know how to pronounce it so forgive me
guys
obviously it's based in australia
because they're the they all are they
all are
so once a male anti-china's it's
similar just to give you context of what
anti-chinese is um
the picture will be right there um it
looks exactly like
a mouse per se it's very similar to
another oh okay yeah
so once a male anti-chinese is ready to
mate
he'll seek out a group of females and
have sex with
every single one of them going at it for
over 10 hours at a time with each one
in fact he doesn't stop mating until his
first starts to fall off
his body starts to fall apart and he
dies gonna say that again
he has sex with every single one of them
going at it for 10 hours at a time
he doesn't stop until his fur falls off
his body falls apart and he
dies bro these
mice go at it wow
the last chick he [ __ ] in that group
he's not in blood i'm telling you dust
and blood
dust and blood that's all he's not in
geez
yes bro yes bro these
oh the females are happy it's not even
the females yes they are happy but it's
trauma it's trauma
they're sore and swollen 10 hours each
each
how does he do it man starts going bald
he's not he's banging and shivering and
shredding and
just coughing himself in time i said ah
i can't
it makes no sense that doesn't make any
sense no
he just bangs until he dies and that's
just until he does that's just his life
mission complete that's him done that's
him done bro
wow wow it's crazy
wow but yeah i'm pretty sure the
australian um
fan base may or may already not know
about this so yeah
for those that don't live in australia
here's your fun fact so that was your
fun fact rather
flipping heads crazy i couldn't i
couldn't
i couldn't imagine [ __ ] a chick
and then another chick and then like
back to back 10
hours bro back to back like off
it makes sense why he deteriorates of
course it does make
sense bro i would deteriorate just from
the first ten hour shift
oh rags right i'd collapse my abs will
be cramping
you know then ones where she's on top
right and she's
she's going off but you start to get
have you ever got the cramp
the the hammy cramp yeah and when she's
on top obviously she's
not reverse girl she's facing you so
cowgirl so i try and lift my leg shake
it off
because you can't be like a babe stop
stop stop stop
crap cause this is yeah bro
doesn't care i panic when i get a cramp
i scream so i've never luckily for me
it's never got to the point
where it's actually to seize up yeah so
but i haven't even done this thing
i'll just like straighten my leg out and
kind of like try and stretch him or
something
but if it gets into a full-fledged cramp
bro i don't care what's happening
i don't care what mood i'm ruining bro i
scream like ah
cramp she has to get off she has to she
hasn't got a choice
get off i hate cramps bro i just try and
shake it off and then
if it doesn't work for like the first
couple times i'm like babes you have to
switch position because i'm
i don't want to ruin the whole mood
ambiance
exactly because you're good because if
it's vice versa
you know yeah and i'm in a position
where i'm dominating her and
one of them ones where either she can't
uh not necessarily
let's say breathe but like uh maybe her
head is in a pillow
or like i'm choking a bit too hard and
she's like
it's like i mean i'm in my zone babes
i'm in my zone you know but you know
what i mean
i'm in my zone babe don't do that to me
i know you can't breathe but
we're here now you know that's the
reason why
when i get the cramped thing you're
thinking i don't want to ruin it don't
want to ruin her she's in her yeah
but you're like oh crap babe stop crap
she's in there
she's there riding ryan did having the
time of her
life eyes rolled back here swinging i'm
not gonna be like babe stop no
it's not fair you're good egg boy
someone's gotta beat me someone has to
because it ain't me
i'll say get off i don't care
i know if she tries to chat back i was
in my sorry man
you my legs gonna fall off i was in my
zone
my legs finished i don't care
but lucky i i very i know what you're
talking about i have had it before but
rarely really really really really
really but um
that's grim um right i've got a quick
would you rather
this is like a random one some of them
are so random
and i always think this is trash but i
mean
but when we bring it up it usually is
the opposite so
hey here we go here we go would you
rather be there to witness
the beginning of the earth or the end of
the earth what a great question
oh i've never thought about that in my
entire life
the beginning or the end i would
probably
oh i was going to say i'd probably say
the beginning
but then i just realized and remembered
actually no i was going to say the
beginning because i realized
um obviously that's when i want to see
how everything what came about but then
we're talking prehistoric times we're
talking dinosaurs we're talking
gigantic snakes we're talking gigantic
crocodiles we're talking all these
things you know
and then obviously the end of the world
we're all dying i don't want to be there
at that point so it's i'd probably go
for the beginning just to see
okay before you answer can i ask you a
follow-up question
of course if i'm seeing the beginning or
the end for example
can i come back to where we are now and
say okay i've lived this i could have
seen it
or once that's it do i live my life from
the beginning or do i die at the end oh
i feel like that matters okay cool i
would say
in this scenario yeah you're it's purely
speculative
so you're you're there just to see [ __ ]
happen
and then once you've seen it happen you
go back but you
live in it you live in it so i'm not
seeing it through like a glass box no
you're there okay so the fear is real
okay
from both sides okay i would probably go
for
i'd probably go for the beginning okay
just because
no one on this planet earth currently
till date and knows what the beginning's
like
because no one's lived it true you know
people will be there at the end
you know people will be there at the end
yeah yeah there was no one here has been
there when it was started yeah and i
would love to be the one that
knows how it came about 100 so i'd have
to even though the fear of
everything everything would be in me in
terms of i don't know
if creatures would be there if no
creatures would be there if there's even
enough water if there's anything you
know if the gas is even breathable
[ __ ] like that oh yeah but i think
that's the one i would go for because i
feel like
that to me would be so fascinating to
tell
yeah bro i'd love to be interested to
see like
you could go there and the grass will be
rich bro
untouched and you'd be like it could
just smell
you could smell greenery and you're like
what this is what vegetation is supposed
to look like before
we destroyed it all yeah that's what i
would i would love to see but i know the
ocean's
crystal clear crystal clear there's
animals
bro yeah that would be cool to see it
would be cool to see but i know i'd be
the only one there
i mean consumers didn't exist then yeah
you'd just be mean it'd just be you and
some amoebas
tyrannosaurus rex bro and some
pterodactyl i'll be yeah yeah
petrified oh fam i don't even know where
to there'll be no houses no electricity
no
food no nothing nothing nothing just
rocks on you i've not thought about this
because how am i eating
um i don't know how long are you there
for
you tell me bro um okay well let's say
you're
because if you're going from the very
beginning of the earth okay let's say
it's going to be fast forwarded at a
decent rate
because if you're going from the very
beginning of the earth you're not seeing
anything
it's just some bacteria and that's
boring yeah yeah
so let's say it goes from that so the
actual so you get to see the actual
formation of the earth
so you're on just like this one little
rock yeah in space and it's fast
forwarded to a point but you can see it
so it's not just going to you can see
everything i'm capturing everything
it's capping over the space of like two
days
that you get from that all the way to
yeah like mid dinosaur veal okay over
the course of two days
so if you can't eat you're not gonna die
let's just say that
but um so yeah that's what you'd see uh
and then same
let's say the end of the earth would be
like the last
probably like the last hundred years of
the actual earth's existence again
rolled into like two days
so you're just there for all you can see
everything yeah yeah yeah
i'd probably still go for the former i'd
want to see how everything began
i'd want to i feel like it's so
intriguing to me because
like i said there's no one on place
planet earth right now that knows
true there's speculation there's
quote-unquote evidence there's all this
there's all that
there may be scientific scientific proof
but you just
don't know you know people will be there
when this offense
it's true bro um i would actually pick
the end why
i just i'm glad you have opposite
opinions on this yeah same um
i'll just be super intrigued by
human behavior okay in that kind of like
a judgment
yeah because humans don't ever live in a
realm of certainty
they don't ever live in a realm of
certainty there's always uncertainty
about
everything so if i do this if i make
this choice
something good or bad may or may not
happen
and it's just how much willing how much
are you willing to
take calculated risk to to do whatever
you want to do basically
um and that's just how human beings live
[ __ ] may or may not happen
but when you know for a fact
for a categorical fact that the world is
ending
either next year or tomorrow or in 100
years or whatever
i would love to see how humans actually
start to behave
okay if it's a fact now we we're gonna
be dead
in a year's time all of you man i hope
you know that
i'd love to know i'd love to just see
because i can just imagine people
[ __ ] on the street
yeah everyone's gonna start getting into
drugs is everyone going to start getting
really religious all of a sudden
is everyone going to renounce religion
like all the
social constructs that we spent
thousands of thousands of years
building up yeah i'd love to know when
push comes to shove
who holds on to what and who just says
[ __ ] it and let's go what's the point
yeah and then just does whatever they
want and when they're doing really truly
whatever they want what are they doing
yeah
i'd be fascinated that's a great that's
a great point
i still was i yeah i am still sticking
with my choice but that's a very very
very good point
a very good point
i like that it's cool let us know what
you guys picked yeah yeah i'll be
intrigued
that's very very very intriguing as soon
as you bought them like the social
constructs and things like religion
and blah blah blah what you do it made
me think a bit more which is good
i think they'll be juicy that would be
very but yeah yours is obviously going
to be crazy juicy
no matter what happens it's crazy yeah
yeah no matter what happens that's a
very good question
that is a very good question it is
actually again would you rather that's
one of the ones i read and arishi i
thought
what the [ __ ] about what kind of
question is that
um but yeah that's interesting um
you said you had a scenario for me today
okay so there's this thing on um
i follow um i'm just bait on instagram
yeah yeah and they've got this
confessions box thing have you seen it
someone sent that to me like the other
day
jokes bro jokes um so there's one that i
um screenshot i was going to do it i
think
a couple episodes ago i completely
forgot so here's one
um so imagine imagine this is you yeah
so let's say you slept with a random
girl six seven years ago
and you had a full head of hair and you
never saw her again up until
march 2021. so you saw her last month
two months ago
okay yeah um when your brother this is
why
i'm this is why it's good for you
because you actually have a brother okay
yeah so your brother invited her
and introduced her to the family as a
girlfriend so you had a thing with this
girl six seven years ago
but now you're bold and you've got
you've gained two more stones so she
doesn't recognize you
but you have every recollection of her
yes what do you do so she's now going
out with my brother
she's going out with me but you slept
with her it was like a one night stand
bish bash bosh you did the thing to her
and you dipped and i was buff then you
were buff then i'm
chubby and you're champion bold now but
you remember her and you remember it and
she's
she doesn't recollect you um
but your brother's introduced her as the
missus to the whole family
to the whole family you know why that's
an interesting question
why because i can imagine not
necessarily me specifically but i can
imagine the insecurity that i'd feel
in the moment of just in my day-to-day
life
knowing i'm out of my prime i'm
overweight i've lost my hair
like [ __ ] is very obviously going
downhill
and then you've got this redeeming
moment where someone from your past
when you were in your prime is in the
vicinity where they can testify
and not necessarily tell everyone that
you just laid the thing down or whatever
yeah yeah yeah but it's almost just like
a glimpse into the past
yeah that you might relish in
and all you need to do is [ __ ] over your
brother in that situation
and but like i don't know like obviously
you don't want to do that
but then it might be a case of like ah
as you're like as your ego as a man you
might be like
ah i don't know especially if you think
she's banging
and obviously your brother thinks she's
banging and your family and stuff like
that you might want to
i don't i really don't know but i can
see the the
the temptation to be like oh snap like
funny story we used to have a little
me and a little would you call it
um especially yeah
if she doesn't recognize you at all yeah
it would
burn you know what i mean it'll burn
because you're already insecure about
how
different you look to when you were like
in your source
and all of a sudden someone who was
actually there doesn't even know who you
are anymore by look just by looking at
you
and then your brother who's younger than
you in his prime
has secured the thing and you're just
here
and it must be a big pill to swallow to
be grown up enough to just be like
i'm not gonna say [ __ ] i'm just gonna
leave them to do their thing
she doesn't recognize me great let's
just leave him to do that
okay here's a here's a follow-up
scenario to that scenario okay of course
obviously she's introduced
he's introduced her to the farm
obviously you clearly all don't live in
the same yard yeah so you've gone away
now
you've seen her you remember her and
your ego has been hurt
yeah so that in turn has made you want
to fix your life up
not necessarily because of her but like
it was a quick moment
yeah yeah i need to change this it's a
rock bottom rock bottom moment you start
hitting the gym again
you start to get yeah with the hair
there's only so much you can do you know
what i mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah turkey or your bust
yeah i can go and cut turkey
you've got the beard though you've got
the beard though all right so you hit
the gym
obviously six seven years ago you still
had the tats remember that
so you hit the gym a year later you guys
do another family reunion
the first time you saw you were fully
obviously you were big you're a big guy
back then yeah yeah
fully clothed up to here yeah c9 yeah
yeah
now the skin's out skin's out now yeah
next summer you might have a little
barbecue at
your brother's yard obviously the gal is
there you got the short sleeves on you
got the short shorts on you've got the
jordans on
you're looking clean i bet you got the
salt and pepper beard
yeah the clean shave yep you're looking
clean yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah she sees you you see her
and it's one of those moments where
obviously because you remember her the
first time
you already know you're gonna remember
her the second time
but she's now seeing you in a different
light
she's seen you oh my god he looks so
much different to the first time i saw
him it's that initial thing
and then she starts slowly putting
things together yes yes yes she's seen
the sleeves yeah yeah yeah
she somewhat remembers oh i [ __ ] a guy
that's out of sleep before a few years
not a few years ago like almost a decade
ago yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's something because your sleeve
stands out yeah it's not like a random
tattoo yeah
yeah it stands out you know so it's one
of them ones where
it would stick out to her and then she
starts to
not necessarily talk to you a bit more
because of the sleeve thing but she's
talks to you a bit more just to get to
know what you're about she's just
inquisitive she's just inquisitive yeah
yeah
asking you um about what you do
currently a bit about your past
she's being a bit more familiar but
you're none the wiser you're just
talking and blah blah but obviously you
know the situation
you [ __ ] her before she you know your
brother doesn't and obviously does she
doesn't remember
okay boom the party's done now you guys
are cool you've had a good conversation
you feel good about yourself this time
you feel great about yourself i [ __ ]
bet
because the first time she wasn't really
giving you much conversation
yeah this time obviously she's your
brother's girl you weren't expecting
that kind of lovey-dovey but
she's made you feel a bit a little
better about yourself it's give you a
bit more confidence to
approach other women and like try and be
the saucy guy
okay yeah yeah yes yes yes yes yes so
obviously it's summertime now like i
said before
another ting rolls around and maybe your
mom's doing something
maybe you're doing something at your
yard obviously you fought your brother
you write your mommy about your dad and
obviously your brother invites
the missus but me in that month
her brain starts to do a bit of working
she's doing a bit of research now she's
she's hitting up facebook she's talking
to your brother
about you okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
i was catching up i spoke to james um
last month at the barbecue blah blah we
just got to know each other a bit more
and he's like oh yeah and he said he
says something
that probably triggers her memory in the
sense that oh
oh yeah he used to go to coventry uni
for example
yeah and then she's like bang i've been
to comic oh around what year blah blah
blah
and he says what two thousand and let's
say uh she kept that she was there for
a stint in like 2011. and she um
obviously she knows you went there from
nine to 12 or whatever and you're like
2011
and she's like ah okay
okay unbeknownst to him your brother
she starts doing a bit of a bit of a bit
of research yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah now fast
forward to
your barbecue at your yard like i said
that order family there
they've all come through now hi hi hi
pleasantries pleasantries pleasantries
you're in the kitchen now everyone's in
a garden you're in the kitchen oh do you
guys want a drink do you guys want a
drink and she's like let's say her name
is um catherine for example
um catherine is like oh i'll come and
help you i'll come and help you of
course you're [ __ ] oh yeah cool
comfort
yeah again none the wiser yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm over this now you're over this
the
initial thing she put me down she
brought him back up and i'm done now
you're done all right
oh can you help me grab this you can
grab this and she's like james
you're like yeah yeah yeah what was that
james
i'm like yo what's up bro what's up yeah
yeah
no no no james
are you like she's looking at you
looking at her you're like
yeah yeah yeah yeah what's up yeah yeah
and like she starts to say like
why do i feel like it sounds weird but i
feel like i know you
obviously yes i'm i'm with your brother
yeah yeah yeah but i feel like i know
you
is it just me or am i
wrong here and then you now you're a for
you're in a fork in a road
do you come clean and say okay i
actually
i knew when i first saw you like you
were the guy i thought ten
seven eight years ago yeah yeah yeah
what do you flat out lie
oh because bear in mind like i said
she's done her research
yeah she knows something yeah what do
you do
good question
hmm okay
i'm thinking about what i
what i'm saying i would do and what i
think
i would actually do knowing me okay
knowing you right now
right situation knowing me right now
what i'd actually do
versus okay both say both so what i'd
probably
actually do is get scared in the moment
and [ __ ] lie
okay because in my head i'm like
i'll be running bro i'll be running
through a million things so she's like
so she's like oh okay cool
like i feel like i know you i'm like why
do i feel like i know you and sort of
stuff
in my head i'll be like okay cool i
might as well just tell her like i knew
the whole time that
we'd [ __ ] all this stuff and obviously
you were my brother and i didn't want to
be awkward so i kind of just left it and
clearly you didn't even recognize me so
far this is even better
but then i don't want her thinking
that i'm a creep that's always had this
in my head
i never discussed it and every time
we've spoken
she thinks that i've been thinking about
the past yeah
i would hate that so on my head i'd be
thinking no because if you say that you
knew the whole time she's gonna be
thinking that you're always thinking
about it
and every conversation you've had all
these family reunions she's gonna be
thinking
it's been in the back of your mind the
whole time and you just didn't bring it
up
because you're a [ __ ] creep yeah so
then i'll probably be like i'm just
gonna lie yeah and then i lean more into
the line because then i'll be like oh
well
to be fair if you lie then you seem kind
of cool
because then you're just like oh man i
don't remember who i thought it's like
i can't i can't keep tabs on this puzzle
i can't keep tabs yeah um so then
knowing me i'd probably just be like
uh i don't know do you know me like i'll
probably just inquire more
answer i'll i'll probably put myself in
a business right answering questions
with more questions
yes until we don't give up so much
information yeah yeah yeah yeah
so earnest not on me yes if
she wants to figure site and actually
just figure it out don't put it on me
so she's like oh why do i feel like i
know you somewhere where do i feel like
i know you
and i say well i don't know why do you
feel like you know me
i don't know why do you feel like you
know me and i'm just waiting for her fam
i just i don't know like my brother said
you were in commentary i was in
commentary and i was like oh
okay when were you in coventry because i
know when i was there
yeah yeah yeah that's what i'll just
answer questions i'll answer questions
with more questions
until it's so black and white yeah
to the point where i would then
eventually if it's to the point where
she's like
oh my god i remember i wouldn't
i wouldn't want to ruin the situation
once she's remembered
i'm like call this on you now yeah i
would immediately pretend like i just
remembered as well
but then make it seem like it's such a
minor that don't even want to talk about
it yeah yeah yeah yeah
so when she's like oh like coventry this
and that that that and
oh did you ever go to this club like did
you ever go to hush and all that stuff
like yeah yeah yeah pretend like i don't
know and then she's like ah
i remember i would be like i remember as
well
cool let's leave it there leave it as
that i would say i know
i would say i know exactly what you're
gonna say i remember as well let's leave
it there yeah
i remember as well now i know now that
you're talking i know exactly who you
are
and let's just leave it there i'll i'm
done
okay okay okay okay scenario part three
okay
cool so you've left it there now um you
guys go back
so you've gone from the kitchen back to
the garden everyone's panning out their
drinks chin matching watching watching
my trimmer everyone's had a good time
they leave your yard because i think
they're at your yard before they all
leave they'll leave they'll leave
um and let's say it's around 8 p.m
10 p.m so two hours later you're
chilling chilling chilling you're
cleaning up
you're relaxing your feet up you've got
something on tv
your phone rings it's your brother oh no
do you pick up if it was actually my
brother
i would pick up mm-hmm in this and
actually no because i'm saying like
obviously this is an actual scenario
okay this is an actual scenario with
actually me and actually my brother yeah
then yeah i'd 100
pick up okay because we are so close
yeah that no matter what he has to say
and he's not insecure enough
to be like oh no no no it's a chuck it
to me
because it's like don't hate the player
bro hate the game
hate the game you knew what it was
you knew your brother was out in these
streets don't bring your insecurities to
me
you leave that [ __ ] at the door play
boys yeah don't come with that
yeah yeah because my brother knows that
like my actual brother knows that if he
ever tried to bring me on any kind of
negative hype
i would bully him like with sarcasm or
bully him
i'll make fun of him yeah and he knows
he doesn't want to give me that
that strength yeah he didn't want to
give me that ammo to be like oh what
have i just heard that you [ __ ] my goal
back in the day and i'm like cause i
[ __ ] everyone's goal
play boy
i [ __ ] everyone's goal back in the day
home slice
come on now play boy young buck
young
two need me not to hear me son come on
now don't get lost in the sauce
you know what your brother's working
with i'm cream of the crop
i'm king kong in this [ __ ]
oh bro that's hilarious yeah man
i own this [ __ ] you just live here
i would run him for 10 minutes straight
so he knows he knows that about me so he
knows [ __ ] up
if he's calling me he could never come
with me that kind of hype because he'll
be crying by the time he comes off the
phone
so if he rang me in that moment i would
answer because i know he's not coming to
me in beef
he might say like so i heard that such
and such and i'm like yeah
so your brother yeah so i heard it so i
heard that but you're proud of yourself
yeah that's my brother that's your
brother you emulate him so much
yeah bro and i'm like it is what it is
son what do you want me to do
and i'll say i don't know man he's weird
and then he was like yeah it's weird and
then he'd just like he was like yeah my
brother would be like yes weird let's
not talk about it anymore about cool
and that will be the end of it cause
yeah he wouldn't come with me with any
come at me with any kind of beef
scenario four oh okay here we go
um scenario four okay there's another
get no they're not even necessarily a
get together
it's your brother's birthday so you have
to be kind of yeah he's dominating at
his yard
obviously the missus is there um
this time you've got someone so you
bring a thing with you obviously you're
back in your prime
yeah yeah salt and pepper beard skin but
the tats
and the body is doing bits for you yeah
it's too good to waste it's too good to
waste yeah someone needs to hold on
someone needs to hold on so you got a
ting on your arm you walk into your
brother's yard now
she sees you you see her you've kept it
strong we
we all three of you know what's happened
but you don't talk about it
she's seen you bring a ting the thing's
a spice obviously
and you're chin and chin and chilling
you're celebrating your brother's
birthday yeah yeah yeah
dad's there he's boys are there his
girls are there everyone's having a good
time
you go upstairs you want to quickly go
piss but as you want to go in
your brother's girl's coming out of
course your brother girl's coming out
yeah yeah
you're both a bit tipsy now do we have
that oh oh
oh oh let me just get oh sorry you've
had a couple of jd apples and apple
juice oh dude
it's it's been sliding oh yeah yeah both
of their lucy goose
and she's one of them ones where
obviously you're doing this thing
but she puts her hand on your chest it's
like just move
just move but she's not felt your chest
in a minute
she's not felt your chest yes in a
minute yeah actually touches the peg you
do a little
a little titty thing like indeed
what did that yeah boy she touches it
i'm like
he's kidding me don't do that oh wait
don't do that
you see her bite your you see her bite
the [ __ ] out of her lip
you see her about the [ __ ] over her lip
and she just looks at you
you look at her and you're like are you
gonna move so i can
do what i need to do like i said she's
done this thing and she does this
just for old time's sake she gives you
the
it's exactly like the when you went for
the butler's in a buff thing are you at
the bottom of the stairs you're like
do you wanna what do you do
and she said just for old times and she
tries to drag you in
do you a like get the [ __ ] off me
is my brother i've got my girl does you
do you b think back to your
when you were in your prime and you were
cleaning up and think i can
10 years later do the same thing again
to the same blah blah blah
or do you actually you tell me what you
do
do you panic do you wha what is it again
bro my mind does weird [ __ ] like so much
stuff will be going from my head
that i'll be thinking like
uh how do i explain it
like i i'll be scared because i know
that if i tell her
get the [ __ ] off me yeah i know i've
no i haven't done anything but i know
her my brother's relationship is now
over yeah because i've made a fuss about
it yeah i have to go tell my brother now
yeah
i have to go tell my brother i can't
keep that to myself
i can't in good conscience just walk out
of that house yeah knowing that
his girlfriend was about to try and [ __ ]
me and they've been together what three
years now two three years
they're in deep they live in the same
yard yeah i couldn't do that
so then like i don't know that would not
wanting to do that
would not make me want to go through
with it but it would just make me just
not want to do that like yeah it's weird
because you have two options you either
go through with it or you tend to get
the [ __ ] off you don't really have much
other
choice yeah yeah yeah and it's like i
would not
i would so badly not want to ruin my
brother's relationship
that it would make not make me want to
go through with it but just
i can't explain it just really not want
to ruin that moment
of obviously she's not thinking about
what she's doing
and i'm just a pawn in this and i'm just
like oh
man just like a quick five minute back
shot
nah i couldn't i couldn't i couldn't i
couldn't i couldn't i couldn't good
like obviously the way my brain's
working in terms of trying to not
offend her by yeah yeah yeah ruining
this whole thing
would probably i'll probably be in the
bathroom before i figured anything out
okay
okay okay so i think what probably
happened is she'd
i'd leave it as long as possible before
she comes to her senses
so i'll be hoping when she comes to the
old time's sake jokey jokey
i'm thinking how long can i let this be
a joke
so all i need to do is leave this house
convinced that she was joking the whole
time
so i think what i would do
is she comes in old time's sake
and i'm like hahaha grabs the shirt
pulls me into the bathroom
and then i'll just be ticking off boxes
of
it's still a joke it's still a joke so
if she closes the door behind her
it can't be a joke anymore if she
actually moves in for a kiss
my ideal situation would be she pulls me
in
i'm laughing my ass stops up and then
she leans in for a kiss
and then i can be like oh you're such an
idiot grab her face like this
and just like sharp yeah and then like
sure and then just be like
gal actually piss and then the whole
situation is
fighting windows in my head i'm like
cool she was only [ __ ] around yeah
nothing happened
let me get on with my life but if she
actually pulled me in and closed the
door
then i'm like she's serious she's
actually serious
and i'd have to be like stop stop yeah
open the [ __ ] door
and then the whole world comes crashing
down yeah
especially if my brother knew at that
point that had already happened in the
past
and then big bro strikes again ladies
love cool james
nah nah it's not fair it isn't it's not
fair it's a blessing and a curse for me
at this point
it's just not fair and my own little
bunny sitting downstairs
no it's just not on it's just not on
fair enough but as a man i'll be turned
on i was gonna say that i'm gonna be
you'll be saying no with a hard dick oh
yeah yeah yeah god
as a man i'll be turned on
oh i think this [ __ ] is willing to risk
it all
brothers and the guys got a ting
downstairs
wow wow yeah bro if you thought that sex
was good then
you know that sex is going to be good in
the bathroom oh it's going to be heated
hated with a muffler yeah because you
have a shut up noise yeah yeah
it's long it's long as long as i
couldn't do it but
i'm bashing that night i'll tell you
that for free
i'm bashing that night and then it's
like good lord good lord let's go back
to the yard again
no you'd have to be like another four or
five six months oh
hundred percent yeah um let's do one's
gotta go
right um this one again is
people calm so
this one in terms of the characters they
play
and how peng you think how peng you
think they are in the show
for this first one so donna paulson in
suits annie donna
sorry yeah any edison in community annie
yeah
yeah um daenerys obviously in game of
thrones okay and penny in big bang
theory
one two okay yeah yeah um
[Music]
in like sex appeal kind of thing i think
donna can go
okay why she's got mad sex appeal but
she jokes too much
okay she plays too much okay i don't
know when she's serious or not
uh my mind will be doing backflips yeah
i think is she down or not yeah
because she's been she's she's been
giving me [ __ ] eyes for the last six
months yeah
but every time i say something on the
border she shuts it down
immediately she's all about harvey yeah
she needs to
yeah i'd have to drop down because i
can't handle this okay
um annie is just like a freak
undercover freak yeah yeah yeah i know
like i know once
that we break down this shy barrier yeah
it's game over
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um obviously
daenerys
oh come on now that's a no-brainer
anywhere um and then penny is yeah
penny's like she's
og og sex appeal yeah yeah yeah um brad
pitt
leonardo dicaprio robert de niro robert
downey jr
and this is based on their acted ability
buffiness no not barfnets acting
movies stuff like that oh okay cool in
terms of like who you [ __ ] with the most
okay cool um so robert de niro
robert downey jr oh sorry robert downey
jr robert okay robert de niro robert
downey jr brad pitt
and leo leonardo dicaprio
oh good question bro
um it's tough
it's really tough because
i don't really know okay so for example
like i love robert downey jr right
but i only really know his roles from
like the last
15 years or so i don't know any roles
before that i know he's been an actor
since he was young
but ever since like any role he's had
since
iron man won he's
basically played the same guy he just
plays himself
do you know what i mean this kind of
like witty slightly neurotic
arrogant uh like charming guy
billionaire playboy billionaire playboy
he plays the billionaire playboy off
like
i'm smart as [ __ ] and i know like i can
have your girl tomorrow
yeah like he plays that role in
everything he does
um which i don't dislike
but at the same time it's like it's kind
of type casting yeah
he's kind of type question like that's
just who he plays he doesn't have much
diversity in his roles
since i've seen him anyway and i love
him as an actor i actually love him as
an actor
but then again i haven't haven't got
much of a portfolio to look through and
be like oh but he does this really well
and this does
really well same is similar to robert de
niro as well mm-hmm
he plays like the italian [ __ ] yeah
he plays that guy
but he's such a legend that is i don't
think i have the disrespect to say
robert de niro's got to go and he has
got some different roles as well
um and i have seen some of his like old
old stuff like raging ball
and stuff like that uh which is like
crazy good so yeah
i think robert downey jr will have to go
okay fair enough
fair enough this one
um in terms of like how much you [ __ ]
with their music at a specific period of
or time in your life um the last one i
only put in because i couldn't think of
anyone
that you wouldn't know why the reason my
point because she emulates
that era kind of thing so you've got
lauren hill
whitney houston mariah carey
and diana ross when houston can go
really this is only this
is purely specific to my life and my
experiences okay tell me give me give me
some
but it's just a case of lush like apart
from
her like famous famous [ __ ]
i i haven't spent any time
getting to know whitney houston as an
eyes in my life really
because it just it just seemed like to
me just didn't
need to okay and
so he's exactly the same as like you
know mariah carey right so
if she had other songs if
if the if uh
like um if she had if most of her songs
were like the all i want for christmas
with you uh all i want for christmas
is you if a lot of her catalogue or if
like even if it was her most three
famous songs were like that
i would not have spent any time in my
life looking into mariah carey
just like i've never spent any time in
my life looking for celine dion
or like anyone else of that nature
like if i feel like i know what you're
about
and the whole world already knows you're
the most famous person i feel like
what's what what benefit am i gonna get
by looking into you
okay do you know what i mean okay but
because i know mariah carey has
diversity
she's got like super rmb songs
and like really poppy songs and like
ballads and all this stuff that you
spend a lot of time like oh
[ __ ] like let's get into it diana ross
um i've listened to a lot of diana ross
just because i like that kind of music
um
like the like what it was like what's it
called uh
like motown kind of music and stuff yeah
yeah
yeah i went through like a mad like
temptation when i was younger i was
obsessed with the temptations
so then like diana ross con and like the
supremes and stuff kind of like
led into um so i learned a little bit
more about donna ross
who i love and then obviously like i
said mariah carey
whitney hughes was the other one that's
a no-brainer
that's a no-brainer yeah she ain't going
nowhere bro
um lauren hill was my childhood um like
her
uh duet with uh deangelo on uh
nothing really matters was my favorite
song for at least like 10 years
when i was a kid i [ __ ] loved it i
don't think i think you told me that in
uni as well yeah i just pre-adorned
yeah yeah yeah like i hadn't gone a week
without listening to that song at one
point
for years so lauren hill ain't going
anywhere uh so on that one yeah whitney
houston
well houston has diversity i know she
does
but i just haven't that's why i said
it's solely specific to me yeah fair
enough because it's one of the ones
where if someone's going
you're [ __ ] nuts i'm like hey bro i'm
not saying she needs to go i'm just
saying for me
okay all right
all right prince luther vandross
stevie wonder michael jackson oh my
i think again purely based on my own
life experience
luther can go okay i'll again i love
luther
but again it's the same as whitney he's
got those
famous famous ones
my like my mum loves luther vandross and
stuff like that so it's just like
i don't know you just don't there's
certain names you just
don't if you if you're not introduced to
much diversity from them
and they're that famous you kind of kind
of just leave and be
um so like it's just like that never
like
never too much and stuff like you have
you hear that and maybe hear one more
and you're like
okay man like that's cool so i think
luther's gonna go
um but he does have some bangers like
he's got
i was the one um
oh what's the song is it called dancing
with my father or something like that
dance with my father again yeah yeah
that was that that was
joe's favorite song when i first met her
yeah
yeah
see that's diversity from the other
stuff that i've heard from him
which means like bangs but it's just
like
i was never really hooked on that era of
music
ever in my life so i never did any
research on luther but everyone else
yeah cool fair enough all right last but
not least
this is in terms of like comedic aspects
ricky gervais
jimmy carr michael mcintyre and john
bishop
which one's trump bishop against the
scouse guy the scout spreader yeah
yeah yeah uh
again yeah based on my experience john
bishop okay okay i know who you're
talking about
haven't spent much time listening to him
um
michael mcintyre i like because he's
kind of clean he's like one of the few
cleanish comics that are actually like
really funny funny yeah
um michael mcintyre and richard face
just don't give a single
[ __ ] michael mcintyre not magma um jimmy
jimmy carr sorry jimmy carr
intentionally tries to make
the most offensive jokes possible yeah
and but he doesn't he's so does richard
your face but richard
sells a story behind it like
um alan carr jimmy jimmy carr for [ __ ]
sake
will try and do a one-liner like a not
like the most racist knock-knock joke of
all time
yeah he's um i think there's a one of
these skits
on netflix he says there's like a
five-minute segment where he says i'm
just going to do quick punchy jokes
and he says like two or three lines out
dundala or dinner have you heard this
joke about short people when he says the
punchline bull and people just like
laughing bro he does that for like two
three minutes bro he doesn't give a
single [ __ ]
sick yeah um so i have to rate that
ricochet face again doesn't give a [ __ ]
ricochet is
funny his stand up is funny
he made a joke about cot deaths in his
most recent stand up
it's heinous but i was i think i've seen
i was on the
floor bro i was on the floor he did this
whole thing where he's like oh babies
and stuff like that they're so fragile
so beautiful and he's like there's just
so much hassle because like
you obviously have to like conceive the
baby and then she's pregnant for nine
miles and you're worried and you run
around you get the cart you get the
nursery set up and you get everything
done
and the baby's born it's all covered and
like it's so precious
it's so small and it's just like
everything is your it's the
representation of your soul and your
life's work and this is like
your soul air and every ounce of love
that you have
is all kind of executed in this one
small fragile little perfect little
angel
and you finally bring it home and you it
you get to put it in this cot that you
built yourself
and and this nursery and everything
everything's so perfect it's fantastic
and then you lay her sweet little head
down to sleep
and she's dead he's like
what was the point
bro oh my god it the way he
hit his switched it
the jaw the jaws you can hear the jaws
of everyone dropped i don't know if it's
a laugh or not
i was howling how do i
this guy doesn't give her a single [ __ ]
okay man's making jokes about
caught death [ __ ] you know bro
nothing's off limits to my man um
but yeah so that's i like that one that
was good cool um
sorry to robert downey jr
whitney houston luther vandross and john
bishop yeah i think if anyone disagree
i'm going to get the most hate of all
time
from those ones from this one yeah i
think so um
so guys so yeah this is like a this is
like a little um
i think it's like a little like speak to
you guys on this one um
so i'm gonna miss out am i the [ __ ]
today
because you guys haven't sent us the
juice juice
this week yeah so i was scheming through
and not to like belittle anyone that's
kind of scent but like
if you're going to send us in and am i
the [ __ ] and it's
like every animal the [ __ ] we've ever
read and it's the exact same scenario
and you know what we're going to say we
know what we're going to say
sometimes it's just like what's the
point in doing it
when they're good or if they're
different and they're interesting
or if we actually feel like you want the
benefit of it
of our advice yeah then 100 and doing it
all the time in the world but we're not
going to force it
but we know you guys love the mind of
the [ __ ] so i'm not saying i'm out of
the [ __ ] it's just like
as and when it's going to be it's going
to still be the most consistent segment
apart from like fun facts or whatever
yeah but uh i'm not gonna beg it when
they're dead
yeah when they're [ __ ] because we've had
[ __ ] once before and i just feel like it
ruins
everything when we have a [ __ ] in my
[ __ ] yeah
yeah we've walked off twice because
they're just so trash so if i'm reading
like loads of trash ones that i think
this is just going to get me upset
i'm just not even going to do it fair
enough i'm not going to do it fair
enough you might need to earn that money
it's not it's a privilege it's not right
but yeah anyway guys
thanks for [ __ ] with us today as per
as per and
your weekend and we'll catch you